in this video you're going to learn
about whether use a sine equation or a
cosine equation when you're describing a
sinusoidal graph so let's talk about
some examples here this first example
you can see they give us a sinusoidal
graph what's a sinusoidal graph well
it's basically you know this s-shaped
graph and this question that students
always ask is you know do I use a sine
equation or a cosine equation and I'm
here to tell you that you can use either
one now the next question will say well
do I use a positive a value or a
negative a value and again the question
is the answer is you can use either one
and I'll show you how to write these
equations several different ways the
first thing that I would do is I would
sketch in this midline now when I say
midline what that means is you know it's
the line that essentially splits this
graph in half you've got half as above
and half as below that will help you a
little bit when you're doing this
problem because what this midline tells
us is what the vertical shift is in this
case the graph is shifting down to so no
matter what equation that we write it's
always going to have a K value or
vertical shift of negative two so we got
that out of the way now the next thing
is the amplitude and the amplitude is
referring to you know how high the waves
are but remember when you measure the
amplitude you're always measuring from
this midline okay
so the amplitude itself is always
positive if it's negative what that
means it's reflecting it or the x-axis
so you can see this amplitude here is
just a height of one one so we know our
a value is one now the question is do we
want to use a sine graph or a cosine
graph well again that has to do with
what you want to think of as your
starting point you want to know your
basic sine and cosine graphs so I'm just
going to sketch them right here so you
can see this sine normally we think of
as starting here at the origin and then
it goes up and then back to zero and
down and back up like that right so
that's the basic sine graph whereas a
cosine graph starts at the maximum goes
through the 0 the minimum back to the
maximum like that they both have a
period of 2 pi and what we want to do is
want to calculate what the period is for
this particular graph now to get from
let's say this point to where then it
starts over repeats again that's giving
us a distance
for pi okay five PI minus 1 PI 4 PI tell
it repeats the other way to do it is you
can measure from peak to peak or from
Valley to Valley so this is still giving
us 4 PI this is still giving us 4 pi so
in this case let's go ahead and
calculate what this B value is and the
formula for this is the period is equal
to 2 pi divided by B or you could say B
is equal to 2 pi divided by the period
in this case the period we set is 4 pi
so if we reduce you can see that B is
equal to 1/2 so in any of these
equations that we're going to be writing
here we're going to have the same basic
format we're going to have amplitude is
1 B is 1/2 the vertical shift is
negative 2 but then what we want to
analyze is okay we're gonna use a sine
or a cosine let's maybe start with a
cosine graph now you see this cosine
graph down here if I was to reflect it
over the x-axis then it would be over
here right and it would look something
like this dotted line that I'm drawing
right now which looks a lot like the
graph that we have here right so I'm
going to make this a negative 1 cosine
1/2 X okay now it hasn't shifted left or
right so my H value is just going to be
0 I'm just going to leave it like that
the only thing that's different between
all these equations are going to be
writing is that a value whether it's
positive or negative and the phase shift
which is a left and right the horizontal
shift okay so that's one possible answer
here right the next one is let's maybe
take a sine graph now so we're going to
say sine we still have the 1/2 we still
have the negative 2
now remember sine starts here at the
origin and it goes up and then down and
back up so you can see this would be
like a starting point but what's
happening is is shifting to the right pi
so when we shift to the right that's
going to be minus pi remember the one
that's grouped with the ax has the
opposite effect on the graph minus pi is
actually shifting right pi plus pi Oh
shifting left pi ok and then the other
question is is that has it been
reflected or not well this one hasn't
been reflected you can see it's same
shape as this graph here it's just being
shifted right so that means the
amplitude is just going to be one it's
not going to be multiplied by a negative
okay let's take a look at another
example let's maybe say for example we
want to do a sine graph
but we want to make it a negative
amplitude this time okay so all this
information here is staying the same the
only thing that's changing is the fact
that this is going to be a negative so
it's reflecting over the x-axis so what
does that look like well that looks
something like it's starting here now
right okay and it's going down back up
and like that so that means now it's
being shifted to the left pi which means
that this is actually to be an opposite
plus pi okay remember the one group of X
is the opposite effect on the graph and
let's do maybe a cosine graph and we'll
just make this a positive one this time
the B value is the same the vertical
shift is the same but now let's see so
if we do a positive cosine now cosine
you can see starts over here at the max
okay so we could either use this point
here or we could use this point here
doesn't really matter there's an
infinite number of ways to write this
equation for this graph it's just a
matter of how far you want to shift it
left and right whether you want to use
sine or cosine and whether you want it
to be a multiplied by negative one
meaning it's reflecting so let's just go
ahead and use this point over here so
that means it's shifting to the left two
pi which means that this is going to be
plus two pi so any one of these would be
the correct answer how do you know which
one to use well if your teacher
specifies it has to be a cosine graph
you'd want to use one of those two if
it's a sine graph one of those two but
make it easier on yourself you don't
want to be shifting the graph way over
here and then way over here try to pick
something that's close ideally you might
not have to shift it at all and that's
what I did in this first example I
thought that was the easiest was just to
think of it as a cosine graph that it's
only been shifted down but it was
reflected over the x-axis first so I
hope this helped you understand how to
work with you know writing an equation
sine or cosine equation given a graph
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to helping you in the future
videos I'll talk to you soon